i mean i really cared more about the
business and running our clothing stores
at the beginning and more the business
behind it
thinking like oh we'll do a reality show
dolls it's the
end of an era the keeping up with the
kardashians era
it's true kim kardashian broke the news
on her instagram
tuesday revealing in the caption that
after 14 years
the iconic reality series will end with
its 20th and final season
in early the 39 year old reality star
said the famous family made the
difficult decision with heavy hearts
and paid tribute to their loyal fans for
so much love over the years
quote we are beyond grateful to all of
you who have watched us for
all of these years through the good
times the bad times
the happiness the tears and the many
relationships and children
we'll forever cherish the wonderful
memories and countless people we've met
along the way
i was so excited because i feel like
there's so many different stereotypes of
what hollywood kids are like or what
me and my family's like and what a
better way to prove
people wrong than to show them our real
lives we're normal
we work i have to get up every day and
go to my store and
i there might be conflict you know along
the way but
that's life you know kim also expressed
her gratitude for the show catapulting
her to super start-up
quote without keeping up with the
kardashians i wouldn't be where i am
today
this show made us who we are and i will
be forever in debt to everyone who
played a role
in shaping our careers and changing our
lives forever
we film 12 to 18 hours a day there's so
much footage
the k crew first burst onto our screens
in october 2007
following the lives of kim and her now
a-list family
kris jenner courtney chloe and rob
kardashian
kendall and kylie jenner and more we
watched as the famous fam experienced
major life milestones like weddings
divorces
babies health journeys and growing
business ventures
and we you know have always stayed true
to who we are and
always shared pretty much everything
as for the oldest sister courtney she
admitted to et in november that she's
toyed with the idea
of leaving the show you mentioned that
you might be ready to say goodbye to
keeping up with the kardashians
where are you at on that um i'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom
and you know put more of my energy there
and still
but i'm not saying goodbye right but i
think you'll have to see
more of it on the new season season 18
which is crazy it isn't airing yet but
it's being filmed
at least for now we can still keep up
with the kardashians
season 19 premieres september 17th on
e g goodbye
you